we're still waiting for the government
to decide whether kids should get the
coveted vaccine 16 to 17 year olds and
younger children with underlying health
conditions are being vaccinated but not
otherwise healthy 12 to 15 year olds
it's expected that cases will rise as
children return to the classroom
infection rates in teenagers are already
higher here we can see the highest
infection rate is currently between 15
and 24 year olds high infection rates
are an argument for the vaccination but
the health risks of covid are low for
young people recent data for england
shows the risk of death for under 18s is
two per
1 million children
and the chances of someone under 18
being admitted to intensive care is
around 1 in 50
000
but scientists are concerned about the
long-term impact of covert latest
published research suggests up to one in
seven children who have covered may have
symptoms linked to the virus some 15
weeks later the jcvi who make the
decision on the rollout have to consider
the risk of covid outweighing the risk
of the vaccine the medicines regulator
has already given the green light for
the pfizer and moderna jabs for those
aged 12 and over and other countries
such as france spain and the usa are
already administering the jab to young
people we understand the jcvi is still
waiting to consider more data but
are they moving too slow
here we have to throw everything we know
at it not just the hard facts of what we
know for absolute certain
we need to take a judgment on what we
don't know for certain but can guess at
and i think they're being
more cautious about the side effects of
vaccination than they are about the
long-term sequelae of the disease
and the vaccine for children is not the
only big decision that jcvi has to take
the government is still waiting to learn
if it should begin its autumn booster
campaigns other countries have started
administering third jabs after fears of
waning antibodies let's look at israel
it's seeing a surging case is due to the
delta variant for 45 days the number of
severely ill hospitalized patients
doubled every 10 days that's this yellow
line and here it was projected to reach
but two weeks after the third dose
campaign started that's this dotted line
through the middle this exponential
growth slowed and you can see this on
the dark line the number of actual
severely ill patients in hospital right
now
the government says it is ready to begin
both campaigns vaccinating children and
the booster it says it has enough stock
of the vaccines but it needs the jcvi
recommendation
the panel says it won't make that call
until it has all the data